My favorite too, is like, I saw who the was it. I saw a girl on,
on Twitter. She's always popping up in my.
Like people either respond to her or something. Can't remember name.
I think she follows me, but she was like, but she, like,
she just is gangster on her Twitter. What is it? I don't remember.
And it was like all like people just because Twitter is like the wild West,
like Instagram, you can barely post a, I mean,
you can't post a nipple. You know, some of these co watches ads,
they're basically porn, but like, you know,
these girls will be like co watches and they'll have their watch like this and
their nipple. And they're just like, it'll be like that,
uh,
ping pong thing where the in South park where the ping pong ball keeps coming
out of the, I don't know the,
but it's like co watches on Instagram and it's like, sign,
sign and use my code 20% off co watches. And we're like, where's the co watch?
Uh, it's coming out of, uh, okay, it's coming out of her. I get it. And um,
but this girl is gangster. Like, because on Instagram,
you Riley read is what it is. That's what, that's her, that's her name. And, uh,
and she and I was, and I looked at her Twitter and, uh,
it's like gangster, like these poor. I don't know if I don't really,
I haven't seen many porn stars on Twitter, but this one,
I should look at more to see if they're all like this, but this one was,
and I'm not trying to be like, older than that. I watch porn. I'm not,
I'm not trying to be like, Ooh, I get all the things that porn does.
I go on porn hub. You know what I mean? Sometimes I check it out. I,
and I just see what's going on and I window shop, but, um,
fair that song for my 50 cent use the window shopper.
That was the last song with the descent made. We're like, okay, well,
I guess he's done making songs. Huh? So, um,
so it was a gangster. It was like, just like, it would be like a video,
God, this is a crass episode. But as is what I saw, she would be like,
this is how you, Ah,
it would be like, this is how you stack edit it.
It'll be like pretty girls on top of each other.
Uh.
Like, like there was anybody ever questioning.
How do you stack policies? You know,
like anyone was ever like, ah, I gotta go on ask jeeves.com.
How do you stack Jeeves?
You just pretty much probably put a lady on a lady on a lady.
Also, why you doing it?
Does on a step one, get a piano bench,
have one lady,
one lady laid down and then another lady laid down and then another lady laid
down on her and it will be like,
it's just gangster dude. And they just put that on the internet.
Like they have no parents.
And then another one will be like.
You know, we just walk like this. It'd be like a porn.
Like we just want to make you come. And it'd be a Linda,
got another girl with another girl. And then just be like, and I'm just like,
God that's gangster. I have no problem with it, but it's gangster.
You know what I mean? So then I would like, but it's like, Oh,
and then, but the funniest to me was she was like,
I saw one tweet where it was like, man, they deleted my
ma no.
I've seen a lot of actually seen a lot of like girls where it's like, Oh,
I can't believe they did deleted my Instagram porn stars. I get it.
But some regular chicks will be like, Ugh,
can't believe they deleted my Instagram. Lock-in
stop stacking.
You know what I mean? Stop being so gangster with your meat.
Of course they delete it.
Or how about when you see a girl's Instagram and it's like deleted at 60,000,
but I'm back.
Stop exposing your meat, dude.
You.
Doing man cover up your backbone, rudders.
Crass.
I got to think of different words though.
Cause if I just keep saying it's too much, if I keep saying the P word,
you know, but it's just a.
Of course they deleted it.
Stop being so gangster dude. Oh man.
So funny, dude. That's so funny to me,
man. Why do they delete my Instagram,
bro? Are you really asking, dude, stop being so.
This is you this cause this is you on Instagram dude.
Just squirting all over.
Stop squirting.
If I worked at Instagram, I wouldn't delete the porn stars.
I would delete the girls who are trying to get away with everything.
To sell a watch.
Or to sell a bang entity G drink or whatever.
It's so funny that day. That's so funny to me, dude.
This is a McDonald's.
You know, put your meat away. Um,
yeah, dude, but shout out to that. That's the thing, man.
I love people who love their work.
I don't care if you're a porn star or a, uh,
a ups driver. You know,
that girl loves what she does and she's gangster on Twitter because you
can be, But just don't, you know,
I guess if you're a porn star or whatever, just do Instagram,
like more artistically or whatever. I mean,
because then I was thinking about it and I was like, maybe it's more like me.
That's like saying don't do jokes on Instagram.
Like then I wouldn't even have Instagram.
Maybe that's what it's like being a porn star. It's like, why can't while the.
What I love is showing my taint. You know.
This is the song that I was trying to play.
When at anytime a porn, every time a porn star starts on Instagram,
when she was deleted at 60 K.
[Inaudible].